Good afternoon, everyone. So I'll be talking about the intestinal microbiome and the impact
of the intestinal microbiome on efficacy and toxicity in cell therapy. So we know that
host extrinsic and host intrinsic factors impact the efficacy of cancer immunotherapy,
both immune checkpoint blockade, but also now a real emerging data set in terms of the
cell therapies, both with allotransplant and CAR-T cell therapy. For today's talk, I'm
going to focus on one big factor that impacts the microbiome, medications, and specifically
antibiotics that induce disruption to the microbiome called dysbiosis. And so I'll be
discussing the antibiotic data in light of the gut microbiome and what we know about outcomes
in terms of both allotransplant and CAR-T cell therapy. So here's just a brief overview of what
I'll drill into in the talk, which is that antibiotic use in the setting of hematopoietic
transplant and CAR-T cell therapy decreases commensal anaerobes, specifically when we give
anaerobic targeting antibiotics. They alter the metabolome and decrease alpha and beta diversity
of the microbiome, increase antibiotic resistance. And in the setting of allotransplant, data has
shown that the exposure to these antibiotics is associated with increased graft-versus-host
disease incidence and mortality, as well as increased antibiotic resistance. And for CAR-T
cell therapy, it's been associated with decreased progression of the microbiome, and it's been
associated with increased progression-free survival, overall survival, as well as a higher
incidence of immune effector cell-associated neurotoxicity syndrome, or ICANS. So here is
just a table summarizing some of the key studies that have evaluated antibiotic exposure and
transplant outcomes. And you can see that I categorized into auto versus allo, the antibiotics
that patients were exposed to, the sites where these studies were performed. Two of the studies,
the first two, were prospective studies looking at antibiotic exposures, PIP-TASO or vanc and Cipro.
And then the remainder were retrospective analyses looking at antibiotic exposure
around various time points before and peri-engraftment, mostly. And the impact of
these antibiotics in our transplant patient population has been decreasing neutropenic
fever and also bacteremia. But also when you look at the lower half, focusing on carbapenems and
piperacillin-tazobactam, which are both anaerobic-targeting antibiotics, meaning that they
disrupt or deplete the anaerobic commensals in the gut, they've been associated with increased
graft-versus-host disease, as well as GVHD mortality.
One of these studies that was performed at Memorial Sun Kettering Cancer Center looked at antibiotic
exposure between days minus seven to 28 post-transplant, and they looked at several
antibiotics, so Astrionem, Cefepime, as control non-anaerobic-targeting antibiotics, and then
Imipenem and PIP-TASO as anaerobic-targeting. And what they found was that exposure to Imi and
PIP-TASO was associated with worse graft-versus-host disease mortality compared to those two controls,
Astrionem and Cefepime.
Dr. Debra Ruh
Several other studies have reported antibiotics associated with increased graft-versus-host
disease, which I summarized there and which are all detailed in that review from Blood in 2024.
This was not just phenomenology as it relates to PIP-TASO and Imipenem, because then they also
looked in a mouse model of transplant and looked at bone marrow plus T-cells and Astrionem in a
MHC-matched allotransplant.
They found that the patients exposed to both Imipenem and PIP-TASO did worse.
And I think this starts to get at the question that I often get asked and we also had, and you'll
probably ponder as well when you see the CAR-T-cell data, that it's not just antibiotic exposure,
but what the antibiotics are targeting that are driving these outcomes and differences in survival.
Because when you see a survival curve showing that patients exposed to antibiotics do worse,
you're automatically going to think, well, were those just sicker patients who got antibiotics
and we're seeing those worse outcomes, it's a confounder?
Or really, is there something about what the antibiotics are depleting in the gut
that could be driving those outcomes?
So now I want to change gears over to CAR-T-cell therapy.
All of us are aware of the various CAR Ts that have been approved across indications.
So in terms of this space, we know that antibiotic treatment is needed in the CAR-T-cell setting,
similar to allotransplant patients or neutropenem.
So we know that, again, our patients are neutropenic, they have fevers.
Here's a retrospective analysis from Fred Hutch, where they looked at 517 patients who received
CAR-T-cell therapy, and what they found just in summary was that, sorry, of the 694 patients in
their cohort, 517, so over 90% had grade one or two CRS, but a fraction of those patients had
bacteremia.
So we know that, again, our patients are neutropenic.
When they're going through CAR-T-cell therapy, have fever and CRS, we cannot withhold antibiotics.
But being judicious about that antibiotic exposures, which ones we start, is really
important to keep in mind, because only a fraction of these patients had a bacteremia
that was driving their fever at the time of antibiotic exposure.
So that brings me to our study that was published several years ago now.
It was a collaboration between Memorial Sloan Kettering Cancer Center and the University
of Pennsylvania.
And we evaluated 200.
28 patients who received CD19 CAR-T-cell therapy.
We looked at any antibiotic exposure, and we did see that any antibiotic exposure in
the four weeks prior to CAR-T-cell therapy was associated with decreased overall survival
and progression-free survival.
But knowing that not all antibiotics are equally damaging to the gut, we honed in on anaerobic
targeting antibiotics, as I've already talked about, and we specifically focused on PIM,
as noted there.
And we found that exposure to PIM was associated with notable decrease in overall survival,
as well as progression-free survival, when we stratified both by DLBCL or BALL alone.
Subsequent to our publication now, two other studies have been published showing, again,
that anaerobic antibiotic exposure is associated with decreased progression-free survival.
One study shown here by Stein-Thoranger et al., which was a collaboration between Moffitt
Cancer Center, MD Anderson, as well as three centers in Germany, showed that exposure to
high-risk antibiotics was associated with a decreased proportion for survival.
Subsequently, another study that looked more broadly at cephalosporins, as well as any anaerobic
targeting antibiotics, again found that anaerobic targeting antibiotic exposure was associated
with a decreased progression-free survival.
And so summarizing the data to date, there have now been five studies that have been
published, primarily looking at CD19 CAR-T-cell exposure, and looking at various time
points pre-CAR-T-cell exposure.
We know that many of our patients are going to be exposed to antibiotics after CAR for
CAR toxicity.
You can see that these antibiotics have been linked with worse survival, and in two of
them, they've also been linked to increased incidence of ICANs.
These studies have also identified overlapping bacterial taxa in patients exposed to CD19
CAR-T-cell therapy, and I'm only showing bacteria that have been identified in more than one
study.
So, several candidates for mechanistic cytotoxicity.
So, I'm going to stop here.
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
studies. And in animal models, this has been validated. In one study recently published,
they found that exposure to meropenem in an immunocompetent mouse model A20, which is a
lymphoma model, mice treated with CD19 CAR-T-cells but administered meropenem in the days prior to
CAR-T-cell therapy had worse survival. And another study in terms of preclinical evidence,
mice were given a fecal microbiota transplant from responders or non-responders of CAR-T-cell
therapy. And they found that the FMT from the responders was able to recapitulate response
in the BALB-C, again, an immunocompetent mouse model. And then in a more recent study,
they identified that acromantia, which is a bacteria acromantia species,
was noted in those who had a more favorable response. And then when they drilled down and
used a mouse model that had...
AHR or basically the tryptophan pathway knocked out, they saw that it was AHR dependent. And so
again, now we're already starting to drill down into mechanisms as to how the microbiome
may be modulating CAR-T-cell phenotype. So with that, I would like to summarize that
anaerobic targeting antibiotics, peritransplant is associated with higher rates of graft-versus-host
disease, GDHG-related mortality, and reduced neutropenic fever and bacteria. In the CAR-T-cell
setting, it's been associated with shorter PFS and OS, as well as improved immune response.
Increased incidence of ICANS. And we now have candidate bacterial species in both of these
settings that have been linked with clinical outcomes. And preclinical models are now needed
to investigate regulatory mechanisms. Thank you so much.